McCarthy came up from behind him and
shoved him and she thought it was a joke
and then a Chase ensued where he started
yelling at McCarthy and what Brett said
is that he got he elbowed him straight
in the kidneys so this brette voted
against Kevin McCarthy McCarthy is it's
it's a mental breakdown dude Matt Gates
pointed out at our Miami event this is
so amazing So Glorious that McCarthy
gets a billion dollars or whatever in
these in the in this m you know money
for the RNC and for his campaign and all
this stuff so he has control but you
know he owes people now he's got to
deliver as Speaker of the House now that
he's removed he cannot deliver on those
promises and those IUS are now basically
toilet paper I can't imagine what it
must be like to sell your soul out to it
is effectively the mafia and then only
what like a month later be like I am no
longer in the position to pay you back I
don't think the dudes who gave you that
money will take that for an answer and
so Kevin McCarthy's probably freaking
out and sweating bullets